on se retrouve enfin franchement 2013
personnage qui se promène à travers le
cinéma français l'année dernière voilà
et puis une arrivée sur scène évidemment
en musique
[Musique]
au milieu du village
l'église l'église je ne sais pas mais le
cinéma en tous les cas cinéma
bonsoir bonsoir
changer une certaine
que je me retrouve ce soir face à vous
pour cette 47e
[Musique]
c'est pas les César ce soir non c'est le
25 février
47e cérémonie des Césars vendredi 25
février 2022 à 21h en clair et en direct
seulement sur Canal+
[Applaudissements]
Antoine est-ce qu'il y aura un petit
coucou de José ou pas
sur une chaîne en disant que oui il
fallait que je me méfie alors moi je lui
répond que si moi il faut que je me
méfie lui il faut vraiment qu'il soit
sur sa garde
moitié professionnel
qui est un métier extrêmement passionné
qui est pratiqué
ce soir-là il se passe quelque chose si
la profession vous remarque c'est un
projecteur